[Music]
[Music]
hey
it's us again is it monday it's monday
yeah
right yeah yeah it's monday i'm sleepy
today
what else is new you're always sleepy
yeah it's all those drugs
drugs that sounded kind of bad it's not
as bad as it sounds
[Laughter]
it's lgd 4033
yeah disarm that i take yeah it makes
you [ __ ] sleepy it's like you take it
well it only it only makes you feel
sleepy if you take a full dose of it
usually i take a real small dose of it
but if i take 10 milligrams of it which
is kind of like a street dose
um it's like you've eaten a whole
[ __ ] thanksgiving dinner you just
want to [ __ ] fall asleep because
your body tries to go into damn growth
[ __ ] mode
healing mode i only do it when i've
worked out i'm not healing up
quick enough you know i mean like i'm
like three or four days and i'm still
kind of sore
i'll take some lgd [ __ ] heal up
faster
because i got to get back in there and
start working you know the
motherfucker's got to get big you know
i got vigorexia i guess i don't know
what it is yeah i think you do but it
makes you kind of sleepy you know
well you know it's good for things like
osteoporosis and
combat [ __ ] wasting and the effects
of aging you know
it does it it just [ __ ] had good
anti-aging therapy man
i'm [ __ ] proof i'm [ __ ] proof for
this [ __ ]
sorry i'm still hung up on thanksgiving
dinner yeah it feels like thanksgiving
dinner and you feel like you want to
[ __ ]
wait for that but then you look favorite
but you lay down to [ __ ] take an old
man
nap but you don't fall asleep you just
you just get that heavy lid feeling see
that's what happens to me all the time
like i'm like oh i'm so tired i'm so
tired and then i fall asleep and then
two hours
later i wake up and then like i'm just
up the rest of the night and i'm just
like thanks
yeah insomnia whatever yeah so
uh today we're gonna be talking about
another new movie uh on netflix
the sequel to the babysitter this is
called killer queen but
first we have some shout outs uh i
wanted to
say uh hello welcome and thank you to
our newest patron
whose name is blake so hey there thank
you very much
also want to tell ken cause i see him
there in the uh in the comments
we made some waffle fries with that
thing yesterday yeah
they were they were really good we're
going to make some more so we got some
more potatoes i got
potatoes yeah we got a lot of potatoes
yeah you make the fries the little
basket in the bottom you know that's
kind of [ __ ] that's for lake making
like one potato i'm you know i [ __ ]
got like four potatoes
and uh all right my advice to you if you
do use that method you want to do what
you do in a restaurant you take all
those
you make the fries and you put them in a
big bowl and you fill it up full of
water rinse them out a couple times and
then just let them sit in water
and they'll crisp up quite a bit you
know what i mean they'll get rid of a
lot of starch
and they'll take on water and they'll
get a little bit bigger and
crisper and then fry it they come out a
lot more like you get what you're
getting at say like mcdonald's
the mcdonald's will put a little bit of
sugar they put water in the water yeah
yeah some people will put salt yeah but
um i like sugar in it or nothing
you put a little bit of sugar in the
water yeah mix it up a couple
tablespoons
and then mix it up a little bit let it
sit for a few hours
let it absorb that water let it get rid
of some of that starch
if you put them dead in there especially
if they're not real crisp
potatoes you'll get a bunch of foam
coming up out of there
that's a problem so make sure you soak
those [ __ ]
soak those [ __ ] soak those [ __ ] in
another t-shirt
put some um with a little potato yeah
put some sugar in them
and then rinse all that sugar off you
know when it's time to prepare it
and then when they come out of there
[ __ ] sprinkle a little bit of salt
or some cajun seasoning man some tony's
that's a few [ __ ]
that makes them we still got potatoes
right we can make some more later i got
a whole bunch
we just had some like for a snack last
night like a little bowl
and you want some of those you want to
use those white potatoes white potatoes
and don't don't peel them
just [ __ ] let it roll yeah i always i
was like
and it's sad because like yeah i feel
like a lot of like fast food places and
stuff don't do like this because kfc
like a long time ago used to do those
potato wedges that still have the skin
on them and it's like those were really
good
and i feel like not a lot of fast food
places do that [ __ ] anymore which is a
shame
because potatoes are delicious and i
don't know why let me leave the [ __ ]
skins on there
and also like 10 minutes before we
started recording um i looked out on our
little front porch
and there was a big box there and i
opened the box
and check it out i was like okay i'm so
excited about this yeah i'm so excited
yeah i'm gonna try and move it without
like messing it up press it together
press it together it is yeah
yeah look you guys look this is
the weeble haunted mansion oh her hat
fell yeah it's got the little witch in
it and all the furniture little ghosts
pick it up so they can see it yeah i'm
trying i can't see the camera that's
classic that's classic 70s stuff there
oh
i can't tell you how excited this was
from uh
jamie otherwise that was black marigold
who was one of our
patrons and she said that
i might have mentioned her on the show
but she said that she had read
uh my uh what do you call it my blog
post
about my favorite toys when i was
growing up and i kind of went on and on
about
the haunted mansion and i was like man i
wish i still had that like i lost
everything except for the witch and i
don't know where it was like i thought
my mom said oh it might be my attic but
like she never found it
so it's like i don't know whatever
happened to it and i was like man that's
a bomber i wish i still had that toy
because i love that
and so when i opened the box as soon as
i saw like the
that one white piece like the um the
thing that goes on the chimney or
whatever i was like no
[ __ ] way so i was like so so thank
you thank you so much i am so so excited
about that present
that was like an early birthday present
and also look this was also included in
the box a little tiny
mumbai i got to get some banana moon
i'm going to put the moon pies the
ghosts can eat the mumbai
[Laughter]
y'all don't know what you're missing
that's southern time well like i said
i'm not a big marshmallow fan
well they got the chocolate moon pies
and the banana moon pies i like the
banana ones
of course of course you do because
that's the grossest one yeah
i told my story about making the moon
pie sandwich didn't it
wait you made a dana moonpie sandwich
did you tell that story yeah
i think i did two banana moon pies
chocolate moan pie in the middle of it
tried to eat this [ __ ] was like that
tall
and tried to finish that as a kid i
couldn't give it about halfway through
it i was just like ah
well see you spent too much time 12 or
13 you know what i mean
you know when you're 12 or 13 you come
up with some crazy ideas you know
yeah and you didn't stop to think you
you just wanted to think whether you
could but you didn't think whether you
should
your stomach couldn't cash the check
that your eyes wrote
exactly that's exactly yeah
[Laughter]
thank you thank you thank you so much
jamie aka black marigold that was like
that
made my [ __ ] day made my [ __ ]
month i think probably
um because i've i've been like lamenting
the loss of that toy for like a really
long time because there's something
about it that i really really like it's
kind of like a doll has it opens but i
didn't want to like do it
sandra said i did talk about it she
remembers it yeah i thought yeah once
you started talking about because i was
sitting there going wait you put nano
moon pie like in between two pieces of
bread that's disgusting i was trying to
make like an oreo
like a big oreo something messy it was
like a crust you know oreo and a
hamburger
you know you're [ __ ] like 11 12 you
know you're coming with all kinds of
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] you know well yeah
kids are done you can't
you can't control it it just happens
yeah
all right so anyway let's talk about
this uh
movie for for a little while what say
so um the original movie the babysitter
came out in 2017 uh directed by
mcgee uh might have been his first movie
i'm not entirely sure
so i think it comes out on netflix and
was a surprise hit
and actually i saw it either when it was
new or maybe a year after it came out
and it was
delightful it's a delightful delightful
horror movie i never saw
i didn't see the first one it's a lot of
fun it's a lot of fun and
samara weaving we love samara weaving um
she was really good in
ready or not she's also very good in
that if you guys haven't seen that i
also recommend that that's a very good
horror movie that came out last year
one of the things that i will um that i
will ding
this sequel for killer queen is that
samara weaving isn't in it enough
she's not really in it until the end
they got pretty much the entire cast
back um like with some new people as
well
but she's kind of only in it at the end
and i was like that's kind of a shame
because
i feel like she was the best thing about
the original movie because she was in it
pretty much the whole
uh time i can't really give a good
opinion on it because i didn't see the
first one
so i i really didn't invest myself in
watching the second one but i was in the
room walking
it had a really good soundtrack it
looked good and the uh
it had the tone that i tended to like
but i felt like
i felt like i shouldn't be watching it
because i didn't see the first one so i
didn't really pay attention to it
yeah i mean i don't know if you
necessarily have to have seen the first
one
but it does kind of help yeah well you
were laughing and [ __ ] that i didn't get
because you saw the first one yeah
about who the characters were and what
had happened to them so i felt like i
was a little bit out of the loop
so i started doing other things but
based on what i saw i'm going to give
the movie a recommendation but i'm just
saying why probably you want to watch
the first one first
yeah i mean i would recommend it like i
said you could probably figure it out
just from
like a couple flashbacks and like the
way they talk about it like you could
kind of you could still enjoy it
but i do think and honestly i'm gonna
say right i did like this movie it's fun
it was enjoyable like i had a good time
watching it like parts of it were funny
um the first one is like a lot better um
this one's good but it's like not nearly
as good as the first one
just you know for a lot of reasons
mostly because samara weaving isn't in
it as much
also i felt like this one i don't know
i'll get into it a little bit but so
basically this one takes place two years
after the events of the first film
um and if if you remember the first film
where like all the people you know cole
was the kid and like you know samara
weaving was b
that was his babysitter and uh turned
out she was like the head of this cult
and they returned they wanted his virgin
blood and all this other stuff so he had
to like kill them and like fight them
off
so it's two years later apparently no
one
believes cole about what happened
because all the bodies disappeared
because you know supernatural demonic
[ __ ] and whatnot
so he's basically um he's in like i
guess he's a junior in high school now
or it's i don't know he's like
two year or he's in junior high i can't
figure out how old he was supposed to be
but um so but his parents are like
worried about him because he keeps
saying
that you know he keeps insisting that
there was this blood cult and everything
and no one believes him because there
was like no evidence
so he's dealing with that and uh so
as it goes on his like little cute
little neighbor
like gets him to kind of like walk on
the wild side and like go out to this
lake party that he's not supposed to go
to
and it turns out that all of the people
from the original blood cult plus there
are a couple of
uh younger people like new recruits into
the blood cult
um come out to this lake house and
they're still trying to get them and
like sacrifice them so they can have
like
magic powers or they can come back from
the dead like out of purgatory or
whatever it is
it's not that important so um
like i said this one is
it's still real funny like i think the
funniest [ __ ] to me was like
the the part with like um the guy who
was like the
the nurse slash guidance counselor like
at the beginning where he was talking to
cole about all that [ __ ] that dude was
hilarious they needed more of him
um cole's dad and um what's-her-face is
the other
uh the other character that was in it
phoebe not phoebe that was like the
dark-haired girl
um melanie melanie that's the other one
a little blonde
and her dad who was like this video game
playing uh
you know pot smoking dork and like you
know what i mean and the
interactions between the two of them
were like really really funny because
just like
the dad like cole's dad was like such a
dad and he was like so
awkward and weird and everything like
talking about like lotion and
masturbation and stuff
and then like the other day like
melanie's dad was just like this stoner
who didn't give a [ __ ] where his
daughter was like all he was worried
about was where his
car was which was like it was like a
firebird and it was like or a trans am
or something and it was like [ __ ]
bright red with like flames and [ __ ] on
it it was like the most 80s car that
ever 80s
and uh 80s yeah
i wasn't sure where i was gonna go with
that but uh that's what happens when you
do a live show
but um teleprompter free teleprompter
what i liked about the movie was the
title of the movie it was called killer
queen
and they did use that song they used
that song and in case people don't know
who the killer queen
is queen's the manager of queen
[ __ ] was called the killer queen
freddie mercury named
called him the killer queen and he was
playing with him he was
real tough british gangster
who was their manager he took care of
him he really took a good care of that
band and they
the band treated him like a member of
the band yeah
that dude was straight as an arrow just
tough as [ __ ] tough as nails
okay not gay at all but he loved freddie
mercury and let freddie mercury just
loved him who is
who doesn't love freddie and they were
like best friends you know so freddy's
[ __ ] doing [ __ ] like giving him
female names
and giving him a queer name and a girl
name and
and he just thought it was funny he
thought that [ __ ] was great you know
[Laughter]
and [ __ ] he'd go into the [ __ ] and
he was tough so they called him the
killer queen
but uh he'd go in there and hold hands
with freddie when freddie was [ __ ]
feeling
bad and you know and he'd sweet talk him
and get him [ __ ] feeling positive
yeah so you know it's just funny stories
you know
you can there's we saw a documentary on
him and he that dude was hilarious yeah
he's hilarious i forgot the guy's name
that's that's what the killer queen is
he reminded me now that i'm thinking
about it he reminded me a little bit of
that
welsh guy that's like ah like on the
fish and anchor episode of the [ __ ] yeah
yeah exactly
he reminds me a little bit of that he
wasn't well but he reminds me yeah if
you ever saw the fishing anchor from
gordon ramsay
there's the uk one yeah he reminds you
of that yeah
instead of saying karen he's like
[Laughter]
calling his wife
he couldn't be bothered to say her whole
name
but yeah so basically the whole most of
the action
like takes place out at this lake house
you got coal
you got all your original cult people
from the first movie plus like a new set
of younger cult people
uh just from this movie and um
there's a new character phoebe who's
kind of this you know rebel chick and
she's also out at the lake
you know for her own reasons and uh you
know she
reluctantly starts helping coal out and
they have to like fight the blood cult
or whatever
so as i said now this is very much a
horror comedy which the first one was
too
um the one thing that i will say about
this one is that
i feel like in a way that the first one
wasn't i feel like this one was a little
try hard you know what i'm saying like
and it's super fun
it's entertaining um it's stupid but
it's supposed to be stupid
um i do kind of feel like they could
have
dialed back on the all the cultural
references because it seemed like a lot
of them were just kind of shoehorned in
it was almost like flirting with
scary movie parody movie type of [ __ ]
like which
kind of like gets on my nerves so they
could have dialed that back some
but yeah it was just it has like a real
wacky
over-the-top kind of vibe although i
will say that like a lot of the kills
and the gore
and stuff like that even though a lot of
it is cgi but it's still
super super funny like that one the one
chick that got like run over multiple
times by the car
and then like they took her head off
with a surfboard or something like that
and like
there's people exploding and like just
[ __ ] limbs going everywhere and it's
like super super bloody
um so i liked that about it um
you know like i said i'm this was a good
movie it's not nearly as good as the
first one
but it's still like a pretty fun watch
and there was like some [ __ ] in there
that like
cracked me up and made me laugh out loud
like particularly like i said the two
dads their interaction the [ __ ]
guidance counselor guy that [ __ ] was
funny
all the gore was real funny um i don't
like a lot of the characters
um the original cult people and like the
new cult people like i said that
a lot of their interactions were just
kind of like hey cultural reference hey
kanye west hey this that and the other
you know what i mean hey kylie jenner i
was just like man
knock that [ __ ] off i was like you know
what i mean they could have dialed that
[ __ ] back a little bit
because i think it'll date the movie as
well um which maybe they don't care
about but
poke poo oh no not those are the
collectibles
she got embarrassed and walked away i
wasn't messing with it i'm trying to
play it off
she likes to pretend she pretends i
didn't i wasn't doing anything you yell
at her oh so then she goes right back
and do it again stop she's
from a different angle no what it would
be
no she's like what what the deal
she's whining i didn't do anything she
did do something yes you did
go play with your envelope yeah i put
that some other [ __ ] i put that special
envelope over there just for you
so look she goes right back over there
and does it again okay
that's it somebody wants attention come
here just pick her up and play with her
where are you running where are you
running where are you
[Laughter]
oracle says i arrived just in time for a
pookie moment
come here oh pokey what's the matter
pokey
don't be tearing stuff up
yeah there you go okay you can get back
to the show
look at her that's what she wanted yeah
well she just wants she wants daddy to
play with her yeah
she's like she knows if she makes noise
you'll come and yell at her and like
pick her up
you know this morning when i got back
from my walk
i found miss beijing our other kitty you
know
just sitting very proudly on the kitchen
counter next to the sink
yeah like what like she was supposed to
be there and i was just gonna get down
from there and she was just like
yeah then i had to turn the water on
full blast and then she was like all
right [ __ ] that and then she jumped down
but i was like
what is she doing i don't know but yeah
so
as i said this is you know i don't want
to say too much about this movie because
if you saw the first one you'll probably
like this one even though like i said it
was a little
frenetic um a little too much
a little too reference heavy um
you know just a little too zany i guess
or
it wasn't so much zany it was like kind
of trying too hard to be funny
i think some of the stuff was like a
little you know trying too hard to be
funny like they were
to the point where it was almost like on
the edge of annoying
but um you know this is a good movie to
watch
if you know you just your few beers in
you just want to watch some people's
heads explode
it takes a bit to get to that but it's
still pretty entertaining up until that
point like it's almost like not
a horror movie until like about the
halfway point you know when he gets to
the lake and when the cult people show
back
up and you know one person gets killed
and then the whole blood sacrifice and
they start chasing him and stuff
up to that it's almost kind of like a
raunchy high school comedy
you know what i mean there's not like a
lot of horror elements before that
it's a movie it's a movie yeah
[Laughter]
what was it that you said the other day
that i said they should put on the front
of the dvd
it's like what at least at least it's at
least it's a movie
which is funny i think they should yeah
yeah that's totally
that's totally funny but yeah so if
you're in the mood for it i'm you know
i'm sure it's
talking about the killer queen makes you
want to hear the song
well actually ever since i watched this
movie the other night that song has been
stuck in my head
so you know yeah there's that yeah if
you guys you know [ __ ] don't want to
watch a movie just [ __ ] go on youtube
just go queen killer queen the song and
that's about the manager
yeah he was cool dude i'm not entirely
sure
i think they just called this movie
killer queen just so they could shoehorn
that song in there which i don't have a
problem with that yeah because i don't
see the reference i don't see how
well i guess they're referring to samara
weaving's character b
because she does return but like i said
not until the end
so maybe she's supposed to be that
character
i'm just saying they're trying to like
trade too much like on the nostalgia and
everything but like i said you know
anytime you want to put a queen song in
a movie that's that's fine i'm not going
to complain about it
but i think that's probably the only
reason they called it that just so they
could put them in there everyone's
asking me if there's a difference
between a movie and a film yes
well yeah a movie is above a flick
and a film is above a movie all right
and when you take it
then if you take it up you pronounce it
kind of like the anglo irishman the film
[Laughter]
super super super super class
for me most films are [ __ ]
unwatchable though this shit's too high
bro it's too eyebrow for me
i was gonna say can you give us an
example of a film a film a film
like perhaps something from angmar
bergman yeah yeah black and white it's
just black
yeah right and there's like really long
scenes of like people looking
sternly at one another and you're
looking it's like a combat boot there
for a long time and then an egg comes to
his
pow like that and chicken goes like that
and you're like oh
yeah yeah that was deep man
yeah the [ __ ] the lighthouse the
lighthouse was
a film i don't know what that was it was
i loved that
thank you thank you very much that's for
answering his questions
oh and he says that great book review
today thank you very much
i actually just did i have a couple
other ones recorded but i put that one
up just because
i've watched the netflix movie that that
book uh that was based on that book
and i want to thank you lennon how's it
going it's going pretty good actually
yeah is i'm thinking of anything's a
film um
yeah i think i would call that a film
it's it but i'm just gonna say and if
you haven't watched my book review yet
uh about that book the movie and the
book
i liked the movie but the movie and the
book are very different i mean the book
is like
uh a psychological horror novel whereas
the movie is just like a weird
pretty much a weird indie film pretty
much anything stanley kubrick
is a film it's not a film
film that [ __ ] [ __ ] song that's
that's kind of going into like
pretentious yeah
[ __ ] do you although i'm not [ __ ] on
igmar bergman because i really like
she's
pretentious shit's pretentious did you
ever see
um [ __ ] man what was that [ __ ] movie
that i was thinking of
cherry 2000 is a flick
[Laughter]
yeah we were just talking about we were
just talking about that because on
another
view we were down all right [ __ ]
escape from new york it's a flick
or it says cinnabon yes cinema
cinema is when there's a lot of dancing
in it
that's exciting i don't know if i agree
with that nomenclature
i don't know i think it's got i think
it's a musical cinemas
i think you know like [ __ ] my fair
lady would be cinema i think
yeah i was going to say i would i don't
want to [ __ ] on igmar bergman because
if you guys have seen hour of the world
hour of the wolf
that is a [ __ ] kick-ass movie it is
like creepy as [ __ ]
that's probably like the closest to a
horror movie he ever did and it's like
really really unsettling i could see
that david lynch was a big fan of that
movie
yeah that's what i'm saying but david
lynch does her films
those are films those are films yeah
they're definitely films yeah
depending on which one you're talking
about though because he did a couple
that were i mean a straight story was
pretty much
kind of like a regular movie i don't
understand a lot of the [ __ ] that he
does but it
it's it's at least it's kind of
entertaining it doesn't seem to be real
pretentious
it's not it just seems to be [ __ ]
alien and i like it
even though i don't understand you know
i don't understand
a lot of the [ __ ] that he does but it
does but a lot of the [ __ ] he does does
have meaning it's not yeah
it's his meaning he's it's not he's not
just doing [ __ ] with the sake of like
look how weird this is
no it has meaning it is it has a art
element to it but you don't have to
understand the art element to it to
enjoy the movies
i enjoyed it i guess like yeah you know
the one i'm [ __ ] with what's his name
god
constantly on the phone dude to kill his
wife lost highway lost highway i saw a
lost highway twice i didn't understand
it that's a creepy
but i kind of liked it i liked yeah you
know that and mulholland drive are
almost like two sides of the same coin
they're
thematically they're very similar
although i like mulholland drive better
but i like lost highways too
i'm gonna give it to kubrick though yeah
i'd rather see kubrick yeah
and then i was talking to somebody about
inland empire the other day i need to
watch that [ __ ] again even though it's
like three and a half hours long but
it's like that was a [ __ ] freaky ass
movie i still haven't figured that one
out and i figured most of david lynch's
other stuff out
but he's very into like weird identity
switching and all this kind of stuff but
uh i'm just gonna say stanley kubrick's
the best director
just in general yeah well he's
definitely in my top five top three
even now that i'm thinking about it um
ken says would you rather a book mirror
a movie or vice versa and which do you
prefer to be better if dissimilar
i almost always prefer the book if i've
read it
um not always the only it's i know this
is kind of an off the wall example but
the only example i can think of offhand
where i liked the movie better than the
book was the hunger
um the book was by whitley strieber who
was uh kidnapped and probed by aliens
apparently
um which he explained in his book
communion
but um he's kind of crazy now the book
the hunger
was good but i liked the movie much much
better um just i liked the look of it i
liked the vibe of it
now because i was talking about in the
book review earlier
i'm thinking of ending things i liked
the movie but i liked the book a lot
better because the book was more
it wasn't straightforward but it was
more a creepy horror story whereas the
movie didn't seem like horror at all to
me
now badgers saying all the carpenter is
a film and i'm gonna have to disagree no
he was like he was across the board um
because some of that stuff that had
carpenter's name on it like ghosts of
mars
that was a flick that was a flick i
don't even know if i sat there it wasn't
sure that was a flick that was pretty
bad um what's what's the level below a
flick
below a flick would be [ __ ]
[Laughter]
flicks are enjoyable yeah it would just
be
a [ __ ] you know bad yeah
and some of the stuff that he made i
think was bad but i'm not sure he
actually did it
yeah that that might have been at some
point where he was just kind of like
[ __ ] you guys
just just put my name on it like it says
in the contract i'm gonna go home and
take a nap
but you know [ __ ]
carpenter had some masterpieces and the
thing being one of them the things that
[ __ ] i love the thing
i do too i can watch it over and over
again i never get tired of it that's a
good
film all right horror sci-fi
and and escaped from new york i think
tonally it was a good movie it needed a
little more action it's not quite an
action movie
yeah it needed some more action in it
but man just the tone the setting
the the characters it worked it's kind
of like you know
better than the warriors remember that
you remember that yeah
and it was from come out and play yeah
it was kind of like
kind of like in that in that era in that
genre you know
uh although man i remember that warrior
so back in the day we thought that was
some kind of hardcore movie you go back
and see the day it is [ __ ]
like i said everybody looks like extras
from west sides yeah
this is like west side story
side story they weren't like supposed to
be because it's supposed to be a musical
so it's like
michael jackson's bad video yeah he's
like ooh
look at how tough everything is no it's
not that [ __ ] didn't play out well
yeah i mean you could say assault on
pre-seek 13 was tougher feeling then
it was than than than that it was uh
uh yeah louis also asked how about
prince of darkness hold on something
hold on
there's somebody at the door oh okay i
actually i do not love prince of
darkness i like prince of darkness i
like the idea behind it
um i like uh you know i don't know there
there's it has like almost like a dario
argento
kind of feel to it yeah i got it in it's
just packaging oh okay
um it has like a dario argento feel to
it which i like but
and i like the concept but i don't know
the execution is just a little
lacking for me prince of darkness prince
of darkness is a mess
yeah do you talk about yeah you're
talking about the uh you talk about the
prince of darkness that's the one with
uh that's the one with the canister full
of greens
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah with
donald presents yeah yeah that's why i
like it
it's a mess i can watch it it's like
entertaining
but i kind of i don't know like i like
the concept of it better than the
execution
he didn't know where he was going i
think he was making stuff up as he was
going along
which sometimes works but not always
what was that was that she was her
calling
walking in she walked it was like yeah
[Music]
actually what i liked better than that
even though it really didn't have much
of a payoff was um
uh the fog the original the fog tonally
and just the concept of it that really
should have been a hit
there wasn't enough horror in it there
wasn't enough and even when he
he went back later on and like put more
gore in there
but it still wasn't yeah because i mean
that was the age of the slasher no one
really wanted to see like an old school
ghost story at that point i guess
yeah but you know but uh still
and and you know and what was the other
one that he did that i
that i liked that nobody else seemed to
like
uh he did uh halloween three
and didn't he do halloween three yeah
teach another season of the witch
uh yeah wasn't that carpenter yeah yeah
yeah i like that or he had something to
do with it i don't remember if he
directed her if he produced it
i liked that one yeah well yeah well i
think it's
people hated it at the time but i think
it's kind of got a critical like
reassessment because i feel like a lot
of people like it nowadays
with that as i saw that like on cinemax
or hbo
right after it came out and uh
i had never seen a a a halloween movie i
didn't see one or two at that point so i
didn't have any preconceived notions
right so it was just to you it was just
like a cool it was just a movie
yeah and i didn't really know anything
about michael myers or anything i wasn't
in that universe
yeah he just produced it he produced it
all right i like that that's what i
thought i thought someone else because
it had a lot of the same actors that he
worked with
in it yeah yeah yeah good old tom atkins
yeah
another good one that's forgotten at the
time was the uh the hand
[ __ ] loved it that's not john
carpenter i know that but i'm just
saying
i was gonna say as far as underrated
john carpenter goes i really like body
bags
that anthology we reviewed it a while
back i really i really like that movie
it's good
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you don't yeah i'm done that
right
getting sleepy oh okay you better go
take your old man that actually
i wouldn't we haven't even eaten
anything today i don't think i've had
one i've had one cup of yogurt i think
that's about all i've eaten today and
it's like 3
30. yeah and i had a cup of coffee mouth
and madness was good too
i really yeah i like that one i haven't
seen star man in forever
but i remember liking that at the time
but yeah i haven't seen it for
i'm not sure how well that aged since
probably since i was in my 20s
yeah so yeah that's been a while since
i've seen that so we'll have to rewind
mathematics was a good
it was a good kind and christine i keep
forgetting yeah yeah i love christine
and i feel like that's another one
that's like underrated yeah and he uh
there was another one that his
friend did um he did uh the fire starter
that was a good one
that was um no that wasn't that was
copper's friend what was his name
yeah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] man uh uh i'm drawing
a blank
wasn't that wasn't that the same guy who
did um
video drum no no okay
no i thought it was he did dead zone
david cronenberg cronenberg
all right that dead zone was another
really good yeah i can't remember there
was only a few really good uh
[ __ ] stephen king movies really
well it's weird people say that but i
feel like
the stan tv series yeah children of the
corn was okay
i haven't seen in a long time i mean all
the um it was a lot different than the
short story
but the movie was okay yeah and
christine was good
but there's a lot of good ones i mean
misery the green mile
like [ __ ] that's right dead zone hand
was oliver stone you got it
yeah yeah yeah that's right i have it on
i have it on dvd
we reviewed that yeah there's no blu-ray
release for it yeah another good one
that uh also had old [ __ ] what was
that
what's that british dude's name that's
in that movie michael michael cocaine
michael k and he's possible okay he he
he would scare the [ __ ] out of me when i
was a kid man he seemed like
it seemed like he was on the edge of
[ __ ] you up you know what i mean like
he was gonna [ __ ] slap you or
something
him and the other dude oliver oliver i
knew exactly who you're talking about
oliver
was like one drink away from kick
stomping in the ass i was [ __ ] i was
scared of both of those guys how awesome
would that have been to have seen like a
really bad like drunken slap fight
between michael kane and oliver
they seemed like [ __ ] angry they
seemed like angry drunks
angry trucks they seemed like angry
alcoholics and there was something
[ __ ]
kind of terrifying about him when he was
a kid and there was a
michael caine was in a good one called
the island i have that [ __ ] on yeah we
reviewed that too
yeah dvd or blu-ray i don't think there
was a blu-ray release and it's taking
place off the florida keys here and went
and seen it again after so long and
[ __ ] seeing the florida
the florida vibe that that movie has
[ __ ] they find them old [ __ ]
pirates inbred pirates out on the
[ __ ]
islands and david warner david warner is
in it too
mango if you haven't seen the island man
you need to see that one hard to find i
think
yeah cause like i said we did a review
of that quite a long time ago
i was gonna i was just having like a
funny like mental picture of michael
kane
how much better would jaws 4 have been
if it would have just been an hour and a
half of michael caine punching a shark
that's been pretty good i would have
watched that not gonna lie
yeah all right so uh we're gonna wrap it
up go have some
mexican food because that's what we're
having today and then
tom will take an old man nap and i have
some
design work i got to do yeah so we gotta
cut it off see if yeah let me out let me
out here all right we'll be back uh
tomorrow at
same time uh probably talking about
another new netflix movie because i saw
another one that worked lego city he has
the island that's a good movie i liked
it yeah it was good yeah i liked it
all right so we will talk to you guys
again tomorrow so
bye